hôpital de campagne étranger
[Musique]
que nous avons mis en place en
réponse à la rupture du Colorado dans la
zone d'amascal,
la plupart des cas se trouvent dans la région de Kanana,
c'est pourquoi nous avons créé cet hôpital de campagne
afin de rapprocher les services
des personnes qui, lorsque  les gens
commencent à ressentir des signes et
des symptômes liés au choléra, ils peuvent
venir immédiatement à l'hôpital de campagne
et ne pas avoir à se rendre à l'hôpital
pour un service
[Musique]
J'ai l'impression d'
avoir une sensation étrange dans mon estomac,
comme si j'avais des crampes ouais et  dans les
toilettes c'est pas c'est pas c'est pas très
bien aussi alors ouais et puis c'est là qu'ils
m'ont dit de venir consulter
descends
[Musique]
merci les
gens viennent ici avec la diarrhée et
les vomissements ceux qui ont une diarrhée sévère
et ou une déshydratation sévère on  insérez un goutte-à-goutte
et nous envoyons à l'hôpital ceux qui
n'ont pas de diarrhée sévère dans leur
direction nous nous gérons ici nous donnons des SRO
et ensuite nous surveillons et après une heure
nous les renvoyons chez eux avec
cinq litres d'eau propre et nous donnons des
sachets d'URS  et nous donnons du savon pour les mains,
merci